un demi milliard d'euros de subventions
pour des bananes qui n'ont jamais poussé
pour 0 banane
il y à un million deux cent mille tonnes
de bananes fantômes ses bananes n'ont
jamais poussé ses bananes n'ont jamais
existé
elles ne sont jamais sortis de terre ses
bananes elles ont donné lieu un million
deux cent mille tonnes ont donné lieu à
une subvention de 404 euros la tonne
donc un demi milliard d'euros de
subventions pour des bananes qui n'ont
jamais poussé pour 0 banane dans le même
temps un tiers des petits producteurs
tombe
alors bonjour donc je reviens vers vous
pour cette deuxième vidéo en aura
d'autres corps parce que de
l'explication à donner quand même
relativement complexe et je reviens vers
vous aujourd'hui pour des explications
sur ce que l'on appelle les fonds possee
y est vous dire qui touche quoi
ça c'est vraiment très important les
fonds peau c'est en tout cas le fond
aussi banane c'est un fonds qui a été
mis en place en 2007 en 2007 banham art
pour la martinique devient le
gestionnaire en tant que organisations
professionnelles donc chargé de
l'organisation professionnelle de la
filière banane en martinique le font
passer y ai dit trois choses
fondamentalement d'un petit dit vous
devez maintenir l'emploi c'est pour ça
qu'on va vous donner des subventions
ensuite vous devez veiller à ce que les
petits producteurs est un revenu
équitable et enfin vous devez maintenir
la dynamique de la profession c'est à
dire faire en sorte qu'il y ait toujours
beaucoup d'entreprises dans cette dans
cette filière banane et on échange de
quoi la subvention qui va être à nous et
bêtes à louer sur deux chiffres
le premier chef c'est qu'est ce qu'on
est capable de produire comme banane
dans les antilles et le chip définis
dont tact 318 milton et là l'europe dit
nous on peut vous apporter une
subvention qui est égal à 404 euros la
tonne voilà ça c'est le départ 404 euros
la tonne et ont produit 300 mille tonnes
on s'est donc penché sur ce qui s'est
passé depuis 13 ans depuis entre 2007 et
2020 on s'est dit c'est 13 ans qu'est ce
qui s'est passé on a apporté une aide
considérable à la banane 2
voyons voir un peu comment cette
organisation de producteurs ben ammar a
réussi à d'une part maintenir l'emploi à
l'époque où paradent 12000 emplois
d'autre part donc faire en sorte que des
petits producteurs est revenu ce que
l'on appelle un revenu équitable
et puis bien sûr qu'on ait su dynamiser
la filière pour qu'il y ait toujours
autant de l'entreprise donc quand on
regarde ça déjà on s'est dit bon bah on
devait produire 3 118 mille tonnes par
an sont multipliées par 13 ans on arrive
au bas mot à 1,4 million 100 mille
tonnes à peu près est ce qu'on a produit
4 millions 100 mille tonnes
première interrogation et là on se rend
compte maintenant 13 ans on n est pas
arrivé on n'a pas produit 4 millions 100
mille tonnes
on a produit 2 millions 900 mille tonnes
au contact donc nous on se dit si on a
produit 2 millions 900 mille tonnes si
on multiplie sa part 404 euros
globalement on a eu sur la période 1
milliard 200 millions de subventions
beaucoup un milliard deux cents millions
de subventions dont tu dis avec ça ils
ont ils ont dû quand même organisé un
peu la profession mais en fait quand on
compte ce qui a été donné
schiff toujours disponibles on trouve
pas un milliard deux cents millions
on trouve 1 milliard 700 millions donc
on s'est dit mais pourquoi est ce que on
à l'europe a donné 500 millions donc un
demi milliard d'euros de plus que prévu
y aurait t on se rend compte que ont été
payés 404 euros la tonne sur un million
deux cent mille tonnes de bananes qui
n'ont jamais été produite
il y à un million deux cent mille tonnes
de bananes fantômes ses bananes n'ont
jamais poussé ses bananes n'ont jamais
existé
elles ne sont jamais sortis de terre ses
bananes et elles ont donné lieu un
million deux cent mille tonnes ont donné
lieu à une subvention du 404 euros la
tonne
donc un demi milliard d'euros de
subventions pour des bananes qui n'ont
jamais poussé pour 0 banane donc là on
s'est i pétards un demi milliard d'euros
robbie dans la file
alors que les bananes dont j'avais
poussé ça a dû permettre véritablement
d'aider toute la filière donc on s'est
dit allez des emplois il y avait il y
avait douze mille emplois disponibles en
2007 il y en a aujourd'hui peut-être
plus eh ben non il n'ya pas deux
meilleurs points à 6 mi-temps on a
divisé par deux le nombre d'emplois donc
l'organisation professionnelle belle
marque à la pas réussi de ce côté-là 1
puisque passe de 12,8 à 6000 emplois bon
on s'est dit allez on à tête des petits
producteurs qui sont des petits
producteurs heureux qui gagnent bien
leur vie
eh ben non figurez vous que des petits
producteurs ils étaient 500 20 en 2007
et ils sont moins de 350 aujourd'hui ça
veut dire qu'il ya un tiers des petits
producteurs qui se sont arrêtés donc ça
veut dire que ben ils n'avaient pas
leurs revenus équitables qui étaient
visés dans le pot c'est donc ou d'yves à
l'organisation de producteurs et
labarthe échoué là aussi elle n'a pas su
apporter aux petits producteurs
le soutien en tant qu'organisation
professionnelle elle aurait dû amener
pour que ces petits producteurs vivent
donc du coup on a regardé un petit peu
ce qui se dit au toreo tombe en 2019 sur
une phrase de l'odeadom qu'est ce que
c'est le dialogue
l'audi adams et c'est l'administration
qui gère les fonds possibles géré des
sous c'est elle qui a envoyé l'odeadom
ce milliard 700 millions d'euros donc un
milliard deux cents millions d'euros
pour une production réelle et un demi
milliard d'euros pour une production qui
n'a jamais existé
et qu'est ce qu'elle dit elle dit en
2019 la tendance aux antilles est une
disparition progressive des petits
producteurs
même l'administration le dit alors nous
on s'est quand même interrogés parce
qu'on se dit bon sang cette banane que
j'ai appelé la banane de lucie pourquoi
parce que c'est monsieur de l'uci qui
est le grand organisateur de la banane
aux antilles est encore plus fort en
martinique
et bien cette banane là cette
organisation de producteurs au fond
quand on dit qu'il ya une disparition
progressive des petits producteurs
nous on se pose aujourd'hui la question
est ce que c'est une disparition
progressive
ou est ce que c'est une disparition
programmée
c'est une question ça n'est qu'une
question mais on va essayer d'y répondre
à cette question puisqu'on voit
l'inefficacité totale de banat mart pour
aider pour sauver les petits producteurs
donc dans le même temps qu'est ce qui se
passe bien les gros producteurs et très
gros producteurs et ils sont devenus
encore plus gros ils sont très très gros
ils ont absorbé encore plus de
subventions donc c'est ça qui va pas
c'est que finalement cette banane
antillaise
elle est devenue je les dis dans la
première vidéo un monopole absolu au
service d'un tout petit groupe et ce
petit groupe ce tout petit groupe qui a
profité massivement massivement vous
imaginez un demi milliard d'euros de
subventions pour des bananes qui n'ont
jamais vu le jour et 1 milliard 200
millions de plus pour des bananes
existantes ça fait 1 milliard 700
millions d'euros
dans le même temps un tiers des petits
producteurs tombe bas donc il faut aller
plus loin dans une prochaine vidéo je
vous expliquerai plus en détail pourquoi
des petits producteurs sont tombés
pourquoi on les soutient pourquoi il
faut que tout le monde soutienne aux
antilles en martinique en guadeloupe
tout le monde soutienne ces petits
producteurs parce que les petits
producteurs eux ils sont là ils font le
travail local il embauche légion locaux
ces petits producteurs et il faut
vraiment les soutenir puisqu'ils n'ont
pas été soutenus par l'organisation
professionnelle de de laquelle dépendent
et c'est pour ça qu'ils veulent en
sortir parce qu'ils n'ont rien obtenu
ici ils ont été laminés
et un tiers en moins au bout de 13 ans
donc tous ont peur aujourd'hui de passer
encore à la trappe
donc il faut les soutenir nous les
soutenons sans aucune réserve ces petits
producteurs de sorte à ce que hilary var
et repartir dans le bon sens mais il
faudra cette fois ci mettre beaucoup
d'équité aidez nous pour nous aider
plusieurs moyens déjà vous pouvez
adhérer à errer d'homme on garde
absolument très confidentiel les gens
qui nous rejoignent
évidemment et tout le monde comprend
pourquoi abonnez-vous à notre chaîne de
cette vidéo
réagissez revenez vers nous réagissez
créons le débat ensemble cette question
je reviens vers vous très prochainement
pour la suite des explications sur cette
fameuse filière banane aux antilles qui
est devenu un monopole absolu dans les
mains de quelques-uns a très vite